con nuestra segunda invitada del día
hablamos del régimen de excepción en El
Salvador que según un informe de la
oficina en Washington para asuntos
latinoamericanos facilita los actos de
corrupción en el entorno del gobierno
del presidente nayib bukele saludamos a
Ruth López jefa de anticorrupción y
Justicia de la ong Cristo sal y también
docente de la universidad para el cambio
social del Salvador Gracias Ruth por
estar esta mañana con nosotros en
directo América de France 24 porque el
régimen decepciona ha favorecido
entonces la corrupción en este entorno
presidencial de nayib bukele
muy buenos días Muchas gracias Raúl
Miren el tema del régimen de excepción
es que durante este periodo que ya no
podemos hablar de un régimen de
excepción ya llevamos más de seis meses
en una situación extraordinaria con
suspensión de garantías de derechos no
solo para las personas que son detenidas
sino para toda la población salvadoreña
no solo para quienes han cometido
delitos sino también para personas
inocentes que han sido capturadas
detenidas de manera arbitraria durante
el régimen resulta que se han aprobado
un conjunto de regulaciones para evadir
los controles de las compras públicas y
esto tiene implicaciones directas en
temas de transparencia y temas de
anticorrupción ahora cuáles son estas
leyes bueno se han establecido por
ejemplo leyes especiales para la
construcción de centros penales se leyes
especiales para la construcción de un
aeropuerto de otro Aeropuerto
Internacional en un país de 21.000
kilómetros cuadrados
un tren del Pacífico también que
fue una de casa de campaña Pero además
durante este periodo también rige una
ley especial de compras públicas durante
el régimen de excepción y así han habido
distintas regulaciones que también han
venido a afectar precisamente la lucha
contra la corrupción hay que tener en
cuenta que uno de los elementos
fundamentales de la política
gubernamentales es la opacidad en El
Salvador hay una ley de acceso a la
información pública de de 2011 y
desafortunadamente lo que hemos venido
viendo es una degradación en la garantía
del derecho no solo desde las
habilitaciones que tiene cada uno de los
ciudadanos para requerir información y
que muy constantemente son negadas por
parte de la Administración pública sino
también para la exigencia frente a una
autoridad que ha sido captada por el
ejecutivo es decir en el en el Salvador
no existe un mecanismo de garantías para
el ejercicio del derecho al acceso a la
información y por la opacidad se han
convenido a convertir prácticamente en
una política pública del gobierno
salvadoreño porque es el estadio en el
que operan todas las instituciones de
gubernamentales extremadamente
preocupante lo que dice Ruth Pero hay
una cosa que quiero preguntarle más de
seis meses de este llamado estado de
excepción con el congreso a la mayoría
no a favor del presidente nayib bukele
hasta cuando más se puede prorrogar este
estado de excepción que pasó a ser como
bien lo decías una forma de gobierno el
presidente bukele tiene límites este
tipo de prórrogas
constitucionalmente así Aquí hay una
ruptura del orden constitucional que no
solo es por esta aprobación
inconstitucional de un régimen de
excepción la Constitución salvadoreña
establece un catálogo de situaciones por
las cuales se puede establecer una
situación como esta Y esto no no fue
previsto cuando fue se aprobó el primer
régimen de excepción y posteriormente
las prórrogas no han sido debidamente
sustentadas pero más allá del tema
eminentemente jurídico nosotros vemos
como esta excepcionalidad es ha sido
tomada como también una política de
gobierno es decir este excepcionalidad
la vimos por ejemplo en temas de
pandemia la vemos cada vez que hay una
una catástrofe natural donde no llega a
suspenderse los derechos pero sí las
compras públicas precisamente porque
estamos hablando del tema de
anticorrupción y transparencia pues
viene a ser impactada porque se aprueban
mecanismos para evadir los controles que
deben garantizar por ejemplo la
competencia la transparencia y la
eficiencia los fondos públicos ahora
Esto va a seguir mientras el régimen lo
necesite desde la perspectiva de la
comunicación porque realmente ha habido
un apoyo sobre el régimen de excepción a
partir de que de todo el daño que las
pandillas le han causado al país y a la
sociedad salvadoreña y bajo este manto
pretende cubrirse la vulneraciones de
derechos que han sido reportadas a las
organizaciones no gubernamentales que
trabajamos en temas de Derechos Humanos
pero también ante organismos
internacionales como ocurrió ayer en la
audiencia con la comisión de
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos donde
el estado salvadoreño no se presentó a
justificar justamente este régimen y
esta falta de garantías de los derechos
de los salvadoreños Ruth recordemos
también que este régimen de decepcione
empezó por la decisión del presidente en
nayib bukele de acabar con las
situaciones de violencia y zozobra que
vivían parte de gran parte de la
población salvadoreña por
en las maras no por la violencia de
estas de estas pandillas pero también
digamos que esto va a permitido según
las denuncias de las ongs que el
gobierno del presidente bukele haga
detenciones arbitrarias no detenciones
que no están bajo el mar el marco de la
ley también se ha reportado abusos en
estas detenciones contra estas personas
y dentro de las cárceles que también
podemos decir sobre esto la suspensión
de derechos ha servido para mucho ha
servido para vulnerar derechos de
personas inocentes y también ha servido
para un reposicionamiento del gobierno
en un tema muy sensible para la
población como el tema de seguridad Ya
decía por todo el daño que las pandillas
han causado la sociedad salvadoreña en
los en los informes que se han elaborado
de los registros que se han levantado
por ejemplo la organización cristosal en
la que trabajo en la que tengo el gusto
de ser parte estamos hablando de que más
de 2.8
1987 personas tenemos reportes que han
sido detenida de manera arbitraria en un
informe que hicieron varias
organizaciones que atienden estos temas
sobrepasan los 4.000 ya la procuraduría
para la defensa de los Derechos Humanos
que ha sido muy deficiente en su trabajo
desde agosto reportaba más de 3.400
denuncias de detenciones arbitrarias Y a
qué nos referimos con una detención
arbitraria nos referimos que es una es
una detención que se produce sin que
exista un proceso sin que exista un
proceso de investigación previo sin que
exista una orden de detención sin que
exista por ejemplo una un marco un
límite para que se impida la vulneración
de derechos de las personas detenidas
Como por ejemplo el tener el contar con
una asistencia letrada del inicio donde
hay una un impedimento material para el
ejercicio al derecho a la defensa a
partir por ejemplo de que las audiencias
son masivas de 300 400 personas
donde no se puede ejercer el derecho a
la defensa Pero además no estamos
hablando de que bajo esta concepción de
que el delincuente no importa las
condiciones en la que esté es que
también tenemos que incluir a muchas
personas inocentes que han sido
detenidas por denuncias anónimas que es
un mecanismo que está funcionando en El
Salvador y que además está siendo
juzgados por una bajo unas
modificaciones que también se le han
hecho a la ley unas reformas al código
procesal penal de tener jueces sin
rostro un tema que ya fue sobrepasado
hace mucho tiempo por la misma Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos que
declaró que existe una violación de la
convención americana de Derechos Humanos
en este momento Entonces en El Salvador
no habría una presunción de inocencia
para esta gente solamente con el hecho
de ser sospechoso podría ser detenida
esta persona y llevada a la cárcel pero
también yo le quiero preguntar a rudo
Cómo se siente la población
salvadoreña en general no tiene datos
con esta política contra la violencia de
el presidente bukele realmente sea
disminuido esta violencia en las calles
o por el contrario todo sigue igual o
aumentado como podemos ver el otro lado
de labranza Por así decirlo de acuerdo
en primer lugar lo que estoy referido
inicialmente si hay una fuerte
estigmatización de las personas de las
comunidades más empobrecidas o de las
personas que tienen tatuajes por ejemplo
la mayor cantidad de tensiones se
producen entre hombres de 18 a 30 años y
efectivamente o sea uno advierte en las
encuestas por ejemplo en las últimas
mediciones que hizo la universidad
centroamericana José Simeón Cañas la uca
ustedes pueden advertir y descargar el
informe y ver como la ciudadanía aprueba
el régimen de excepción aprueba que no
que en la disminución de homicidio
porque evidentemente es un problema que
afecta notablemente a las comunidades
pero también de esa prueba y desaprueba
con más del 75% que una persona sea
detenida por ejemplo sin tener una orden
judicial que sea detenida de manera
violenta que sea detenida sin una
investigación previa todos estos
elementos que al final son los que
configuran
pareciera que la ciudadanía lo que pasa
es que no termina de tener claro lo que
las implicaciones del régimen de
excepción Porque son dos cosas
diferentes y el tema es que para llegar
a la disminución de homicidios no se
necesita un régimen de excepción se
necesita utilizar las herramientas
estatales de investigación para poder
llegar a los responsables y determinar
la responsabilidad de cada una de las
personas involu